maîtriser le marteau le feu et bien
d'autres techniques encore des gestes
parfaits ancestraux que gucci répète en
hommage aux artisans de tous les temps
la plupart d'entre eux il les a
découverts tout seul d'instinct et même
à 74 ans il continue d'apprendre et
apprendre tous les jours par exemple un
certain chose que techniquement je ne
pouvais pas faire il ya quelques années
j'arrive faire aujourd'hui voilà donc
j'ai chaque fois aussi nous défient les
difficultés purement technique va une
chose c'est l'idée et d'autres choses
c'est matérialisation de cette idée n
est ce pas c'est pas toujours évident
et voici les oeuvres du maître
principalement réalisé en argent chacune
est unique
depuis son arrivée en france gucci a
utilisé deux tonnes de plaques d'argent
soit une surface de 1800 mètres carrés
une vie passée à faire les mêmes gestes
pour donner vie à la matière comme avec
ce travail de pierre
ces 10 heures et 10 heures le temps mais
maintenant ça devient comme une routine
pour moi je ne pense pas je pense
d'autres choses
je fais les choses très mécanique je
rende compte qu'on peut pas faire ça une
part sous traitance nulle part et à lyon
ça m'intéresse pas à partir d'un moment
si c'est fait par sous traitance
moralement je n'ai pas le droit de
signer à cette pièce pour dire c'est moi
qui ai fait donc chaque pièce est signée
et par conséquence sa soeur ne comprends
pas
pour réaliser ses oeuvres ils
travaillent tous les matériaux se sert
de l'électricité de la chimie mais tout
a commencé par l'étude des beaux-arts à
tbilissi en géorgie tout part d'un trait
de crayon
sa scène les bases du tout je conseille
commencer par ça parce que parfois j'ai
reçu quelques jeunes voulaient les faire
les stages rester un moment la télé je
demandais ce que vous connaissez
il savait dessinée en dit long mais
jamais j'ai appris les crayons dans les
mains comme on voulait j'avais conseillé
d'aller d'abord en stress dans le cours
de dessin
ce qui pousse le maître a avancé la
confiance que lui portent ses
commanditaires et ils sont nombreux
il a travaillé pour des chefs d'état le
pape mais aussi des membres de
l'académie française
peu importe la commande il est toujours
aussi exigeant
j'ai très grande admiration même
vénération pour un grand peintre france
qui était nicolas poussin danse en
correspondance avec son collectionneurs
et créer j'ai retenu cette phrase je
n'ai rien négliger voilà ça c'est très
important pour moi c'est devenu comme
des villes de ma vie donc il faut rien
négliger confère tout jusqu'au bout avec
imperfections si le créateur se livre
entièrement à la pratique de son art
c'est sans doute à cause d'une décision
qu'il a prise jeunes adultes
en 1974 il quitte la géorgie sous
dictature communiste où il lui était
impossible de travailler pour devenir
artiste en france il dit ainsi adieu à
sa famille notamment sa mère qui
décédera quelques années plus tard
goudji passera le reste de sa vie à
honorer sur sept et fils en travaillant
comme ainsi peu importe avec quels
moyens
j'ai appris de faire quelque chose à
partir de rien parce qu'il ya eu des
pénuries de tous donc il fallait tout
inventé et trouver les solutions
parce que c'est pas comme ici vous allez
donc encore qu'en surface ou devant vous
avez les choix et nord des outils des
matériaux tout ça n'existait pas
si si je voyais un petit morceau de bois
des planches de bois jeter j'ai récupéré
médiatement jusqu'aujourd'hui je le fais
ça sans cette enfance difficile vous
auriez eu la même carrière je pense pas
je pense pas parce que les parcours est
très important je pense pas
dans ses créations l'orfèvre en hommage
aux civilisations antiques grec persane
orientale il aime représenter les
animaux
un bestiaire imaginaire
c'est un peu de produit de rêve que je
vois pas reçus par âge et j'imagine où
on se trouvera dans la peinture à siens
donc j'essaie d'interpréter en oman air
c'est un peu un hommage que vous rendez
aux anciennes civilisations aux cultures
anciennes ou parce que ça c'est de ma
racine
donc ça vient de la méconnaissance est
bon j'essaie est toujours faire de
quelque sorte de synthèse
cette exposition en forme de
rétrospective est loin d'être la
dernière
gucci croule sous les commandes et ne
souhaite pas s'arrêter un grand artiste
va jusqu'au bout de ses forces
parce que c'est sa respiration c'est
connaissant tellement bien obligé
personne n'imagine moggi dans un transat
en train de lire un livre et point final
il a besoin de travailler au quotidien o
dia pas marteau entre les mains tous les
jours ça ne va pas mais une question
reste en suspens quel héritage d sera
goudji sa maîtrise des différentes
techniques
son style si unique n'ont pas trouvé de
successeur je ne fus contre cet hymne
est de prendre en apprend c'est pas ce
cas précis s'il a du talent ça pouvait
dévier ses idées ça me bloquer donc il
faut laisser libre complètement à
créateurs le créateur goudji ans portera
donc avec lui ses secrets et laissera
orphelin les centaines d'outils qui l'a
fabriqué de ses mains pour réaliser ses
hommes
[Musique]